Recent advancements in technology
have allowed animators to
push the limits of their work,
resulting in more creative and detailed
films and TV shows than ever before.
To find out how six of these stunning
and unique animations were created,
let's take a look behind the scenes.
Stop-motion-animated movies
have been around for over 100 years,
but the production house Laika Studios
brought this animation
style into the 21st century
by utilizing 3D printing,
a technique that is especially prevalent
in their 2016 masterpiece,
"Kubo and the Two Strings."
Traditionally,
stop-motion-animated characters
had to be made of a moldable
material, such as clay,
so that the faces of the
characters could be changed.
However, by using 3D-printed faces,
Laika Studios is able to
alter the facial expressions
of its characters more
quickly and consistently.
Each expression is created
using 3D-modeling software.
The models are then printed
with the 3D printer,
and magnets are added
to the back of the face
so they can later be
attached to the puppets.
There were approximately 48
million different combinations
of facial expressions created for
the film's main character, Kubo.
His face consists of a top
and bottom faceplate that combine.
The tiny seam between the two pieces
was painted out in postproduction.
Because there were so many faces,
each face had a code on the back of it
in order to keep all of them organized.
Advanced 3D-printing
technology also allowed
"Kubo and the Two Strings"
to be able to create intricate puppets
that would be impossible
to create otherwise,
such as the character called Moon Beast,
who was Laika's first
completely 3D-printed character.
Moon Beast was made of 881
individual 3D-printed parts:
130 color parts and 751 components
for the armatures used
in its body and legs.
"Loving Vincent" is the first
feature-length animated film
in which every frame was hand
painted using oil on canvas -
approximately 65,000 frames in total.
The film was painted in the
style of Vincent van Gogh,
featuring 94 of the
artist's original paintings
as the settings for the story.
In order to create the film,
the production team invented
a special animation process.
First they filmed actors on a blue stage,
with background elements
digitally added later.
Then one of the 125 highly
skilled artists on the team
painted over each frame of
this live-action footage
in the style of Van Gogh.
The paintings were then
photographed and assembled
to complete the animation process.
The producers faced several challenges
in this ambitious project.
First, they had to change
the color palette of
several of Van Gogh's paintings,
because while Van Gogh painted
across all four seasons,
the film's plot takes
place only in the summer.
Additionally, Van Gogh experimented with
several different styles
throughout his life,
so characters had to
be painted differently
based on which Van Gogh painting
was being used as the backdrop.
When the production team
realized they needed
to hire more painters to
finish the project on time,
they discovered that there
literally weren't enough
trained painters available in Poland,
where the film was being made.
So they posted a job listing
and ended up hiring 45 oil
painters from around the world,
sifting through 5,000 applications.
Given all of these factors,
it's no surprise that it took the team
about five years to complete the project.
The film's director said that they had
"without a doubt invented the slowest form
of filmmaking ever devised."
It took producers over a year to create
just 10 seconds of test animation footage
that they were happy with for
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse."
The eye-grabbing animation
style of the 2018 film
looks wildly different from
typical animated movies,
and it borrows many of its innovative
animation techniques from comic books.
One of the most noticeable
differences involves frame rate.
Animated films are typically
24 frames per second,
and creating a different image for each
frame is known as animating "on ones."
"Spider-Verse" broke the mold
and animated much of the movie "on twos,"
meaning that they kept some
images on screen for two frames.
Each character's pose lasts longer
and is much more pronounced.
They alternated between
on twos and on ones,
depending on the nature of the scene.
Another defining
characteristic of the film
is that there isn't any motion blur,
a CGI trick that most new films use
to soften a movement and
make it seem more real.
Instead, they used an old-school
technique called a smear.
This was used a lot in early cartoons
to create the sense of motion.
If you look at a single frame,
you'll notice things like multiple limbs
to create the illusion of movement.
The producers also decided not to create
a traditional depth of
field by using lens blurs
and instead utilized misprinting,
inspired by the common
error in comic books
when ink is misaligned.
When something is in focus,
the colors align and are crisper,
while the colors of background
objects are often offset.
The characters in Netflix's
Oscar-nominated film
"Klaus" look three dimensional.
But unlike most animated
movies these days,
the characters in "Klaus" aren't all CGI
and can't even be considered 3D.
The characters were
first hand drawn, inked,
and painted using digital tablets.
Then the artists were
able to paint with light,
thanks to software created
specifically for "Klaus."
The second major feature that helped
bring the characters to life
and added to the 3D
illusion was texturing.
With another piece of software
they used contour, lighting, and motion
to add surface qualities to
specific parts of a character.
For example, the skin could appear smooth
while the clothing would be rougher.
In the end, the characters
appeared much more 3D
and immersed in their environment,
as opposed to looking like stickers
on top of an elaborately
painted background.
While the majority of the
film followed this 2D process,
the animators did use 3D models
for some characters and objects
and combined the two styles seamlessly.
Even though these were created using CGI,
they were lit the same way
as the 2D characters were.
Scenes like this chase
scene at the end of the film
so seamlessly combined 2D and 3D elements
that it can be difficult
to tell which is which.
While audiences and critics were divided
on Disney's 2019 "Lion King" remake,
it's undeniable that the
animation was a technical triumph,
as it's the most photorealistic
animated major motion picture to date.
One of the first steps
in most animation films
is pre-visualization,
where an extremely low-resolution version
of the animation is created in order
to perfect character
movements and camera angles.
However, "The Lion King" took
a new approach to this phase,
creating simplified animated sequences
that could be viewed in virtual reality.
The director and production team
would then put on VR headsets,
which allowed them to actually step foot
in the virtual set that they had created.
This allowed them more
freedom to explore each scene
and let them easily set
up shots, adjust lighting,
and choreograph movements.
This digital environment
helped them emulate
the nature-documentary aesthetic
that they were aiming for.
The "Lion King" animation team also ran
into the unique challenge
of having to make
the animals not only realistic,
but also able to sing and talk.
In order to pull this off,
they timed the characters'
breathing to their dialogue
and would make the belly
muscles and diaphragm tighten.
That way, it felt like the animals
were forcing air out of
their mouths as they spoke.
Each layer of these animals also
went through a simulation pass,
an additional phase of
animation where skin details
such as muscle ripples, skin wrinkles,
and fur interaction are all added.
Striking that balance between
staying true to the original film
and creating a hyperrealistically
animated "Lion King"
for a new audience was a
particularly tough challenge,
and it required 77 million
hours of animation rendering.
The 2019 Amazon Prime series "Undone"
was created using rotoscoping,
the process of drawing animations
over live-action video footage.
Rotoscoping has been around
since the early 1900s,
but the rotoscoping process for "Undone"
is so much more advanced
that it's practically unrecognizable
from its predecessors.
The producers for "Undone" were originally
going to film the series
using live action,
but they ultimately decided
that using rotoscope animation
would give the series the surreal feeling
that it necessitated,
as the story revolves around a young woman
who has an unsteady grip on reality.
The scenes were initially shot
with actors and minimal sets,
using grids on set as reference
points for the animators.
There was no need for green screen
because every area of the frames
would be painted over during
the rotoscoping process.
The live action was then rotoscoped,
with animators drawing crisp
lines over the footage.
The rotoscope animation
was then sent to Amsterdam,
where artists would use oil-based paints
to add colors and shadows to the footage.
While many of the backgrounds were
painted in Amsterdam using oil on canvas,
some scenes required backgrounds that were
created using 3D-modeling software.
To maintain the uniform painted look,
the 3D-animation team would
send a layout to the painters,
who would paint over the image.
After the painting was complete,
the 3D artists could then
use the finished painting
as a reference for texturing
the 3D environment.
What film do you think we should
have included on the list?
What animated film would
you like us to discuss next?
Let us know in the comments.